I've recently seen videos and read a few articles discouraging eating rice and oatmeal for
a variety of health reasons. What are your thoughts? Well, I would agree. I mean, rice, I mean,
you could find a lot of data that rice contains a lot of heavy metals. You could find a lot of data that
even organic rice contains heavy metals and even organic oatmeal contains issues. Also,
oatmeal could be a cross-contaminated or gluten. It can be cross-contaminated with gluten
because of where it's milled out of the same mill. So if you have a gluten sensitivity,
we need a gluten-created peptide sensitivity, and you're eating regular oatmeal, that could be an issue.
Oatmeal that isn't organic is probably related with GMOs, which is the number one cause of damaged
cuts. So there's a lot of things that can be concerns with any types of grains that not for
everybody, but you have to be aware of those concerns, and that's where getting tested for antibodies
for those things. But even if you don't have any antibodies for rice, you don't have any antibodies
for gluten and oatmeal and everything, you do have to be aware that you have to eat as clean
of these foods as possible. So if you're just going to your local coffee shop and getting an oatmeal
cup, it's probably not organic. Therefore, it's related with GMOs, so it is going to damage your
gut big time. You know, eating GMO food is equivalent to taking it in antibiotic, and that's what it does
to your gut, so it could be very damaging.